ocho años después los soldados franceses
pasan el relevo tombuctú está ahora
controlada por las fuerzas malienses el
simbolismo es fuerte el ex presidente
françois hollande oficializó el inicio
de la intervención en esta misma ciudad
fue en febrero de 2013
para nosotros es una página que se pasa
en tombuctú pero la misión continúa mis
soldados y yo continuaremos nuestra
misión en malinas
pero desde hace dos meses francia ha
reducido considerablemente su presencia
retirada de kidal el 12 de octubre de
tessalit el 15 de noviembre y de
tombuctú el 14 de diciembre sin embargo
miley es un país estratégico en la lucha
contra luz y la distracción el sahel de
los 5.100 soldados franceses presentes
en mali en febrero de 2020 sólo tres mil
deberían seguir ahí en 2022 aún con la
misma misión era dedicar la amenaza
yihadista en la medida de lo posible y
supervisar a las fuerzas malienses para
que puedan garantizar la seguridad del
país mientras tanto la fuerza tacuba que
reúne a varios países de la unión
europea sigue operando en mali el miedo
de parís ahora el grupo paramilitar ruso
wagner algo que las autoridades
malienses están ahora tentadas de
recurrir